There is only one man who can rid the politics of this state of the evil domination of Boss Jim Gettys.
Hooray!
I am speaking of Charles Foster Kane,...
...the fighting liberal,...
...the friend of the working man,...
...the next governor of this state who entered upon this campaign.
With one purpose only:...
...to point out and make public the dishonesty,...
...the downright villainy of Boss Jim W. Gettys' political machine,...
...now in complete control of the government of this state!
I made no campaign promises...
...because until a few weeks ago, I had no hope of being elected.
Now, however, I have something more than a hope...
...and Jim Gettys... Jim Gettys has something less than a chance.
Every straw vote,...
...every independent poll shows that I'll be elected.
Well then, now, I can afford to make some promises!
The working man... The working man and the slum child know they can expect my best efforts in their interests.
The decent, ordinary citizens know that I'll do everything in my power...
...to protect the underprivileged, the underpaid, and the underfed!